en allemagne est particulièrement dans
la capitale allemande on a vu le nombre
de réfugiés ukrainien a augmenté à peu
près dès le milieu de la semaine
dernière la compagnie des chemins de fer
allemand offre des billets de train
gratuits aux réfugiés ukrainien de la
pologne vers l'allemagne et donc on
enregistre on voit aujourd'hui dans la
gare principale de berlin environ dix
mille réfugiés ukrainien arriver chaque
jour tendance à la hausse alors les
autorités fédérales la police fédérale
en particulier enregistré un peu plus de
50000 personnes depuis le début de la
guerre mais ils sont certainement déjà
bien plus nombreux parce que de nombreux
ukrainiens sont venus en allemagne par
leurs propres moyens en voiture
notamment on voit dans les rues de
berlin de nombreuses plaques
d'immatriculation ukrainienne hier soir
en revenant vers berlin sur l'autoroute
j'en ai vu également énormément en tout
cas la capitale qui est actuellement le
principal point de chute de ces réfugiés
ukrainien arrive à ses limites les
autorités vont ouvrir un second centre
d'accueil d'urgence dont la semaine pour
pouvoir faire face à ces arrivées les
autorités encouragent également s'est
réfugié à se rendre dans d'autres
régions et de son côté le gouvernement
fédéral reste très prudent mais selon
certaines estimations
l'allemagne doit se préparer à attendre
au moins quatre cent mille réfugiés
syriens et craignent un pardon dans les
semaines qui viennent